revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya lista en el estudio rosa
pérez + eu rosa feliz mañana de
miércoles hoy abrimos nuestra sección de
revistas de prensa convocadas
internacionales porque hoy es uno de
esos días a pesar de que no hay
elecciones que casi todos los titulares
de la prensa internacional coinciden
rosa y que estamos hablando bueno del
aula hablamos del anuncio que hizo ayer
el presidente de eeuu joe biden de
prohibir las importaciones de petróleo
provenientes de rusia y vemos aquí una
pequeña selección de portadas
internacionales empezamos por el
liberación de francia que dice petróleo
y gas y gas rusos la otra guerra ha sido
declarada si bien recordemos que europa
de momento no ha tomado esta decisión de
hecho el medio también francesa de mont
se preguntaba en portada francia podría
permitirse cortar el suministro de gas
ruso pues de momento probablemente no
continuamos con el wall street journal
con un titular bastante inequívoco no
eeuu
las importaciones de petróleo ruso
continuamos allá con otro medio de aquí
de la región latinoamericana la nación
de argentina también con un embargo de
petróleo baiden acorrala más a putin y
cerramos con el nacional de venezuela
by then ordena el embargo sobre
importaciones de petróleo y hemos
querido pues fijarnos en este medio
porque esto supone un giro de los
acontecimientos inesperados para caracas
como lo estamos viendo ahora venezuela
se convierte en uno de estos
protagonistas en este conflicto pues
pero por supuesto hay que ver cómo van a
marchar las cosas rosa vamos a
centrarnos ahora una pregunta que se ha
hecho muchas personas las cual la cual
me incluyo que ha intentado responder
distintos medios de comunicación y dice
que significa el aceite en apoyo a las
tropas rusas en esta invasión a ucrania
lo vemos en la bbc en al yazira y the
economist de hecho también lo vimos en
deporte segundo protesta razón hasta se
puso el aceite en el pecho para recibir
su medalla en el mundial de gimnasta en
qatar a exactamente
iván culiacán fue una de las personas
que desató
precisamente por bordar la zeta en su
mayo tiene una cita de la copa del mundo
de gimnasia como decías en doha en qatar
aquí aquí lo vemos en esta imagen pero
es que está zeta también aparece en
vallas publicitarias en redes sociales
en paradas de autobús y sobre todo y de
ahí surgió un poco el origen de este
símbolo en tanques rusos que ya se
vieron de hecho pintados con esta marca
en la guerra de crimea
pero digamos a que ahora pues se ha
hecho mucho más popular no esta insignia
y distintos medios de comunicación se
preguntan por qué la zeta si esta letra
no está en el alfabeto cirílico no en el
que se usa para la lengua rusa de hecho
esto responde a lo que sería una trans
una traducción fonética no del sonido de
por ejemplo la palabra esa pad que
significa oeste y hay distintas teorías
por un lado oeste de la dirección en la
que pues se dirigían las tropas rusas
también ya para 2021 era el nombre de
una operación de y obras militares una
operación de formación de las mayores
que ha llevado a cabo el ejército ruso
pues en ese caso en 2021 donde se
simulaba una guerra pero todo apunta a
que pues digamos está z viene realmente
de la traducción fonética de la pobre
duque significaría por la victoria esto
según el medio nóvaya gazeta al que
hemos hecho aquí referencia en múltiples
ocasiones y de hecho este medio
independiente ruso hace referencia al
instagram de las fuerzas armadas rusas
raúl no sé si lo podemos ver a
continuación porque es una cuenta
verificada que pública pues distintas
imágenes de apoyo a las tropas pues
rusas y de hecho ya lo estamos viendo
rosa ahí lo tenemos y de hecho vemos la
imagen de una soldado ruso con la seta a
continuación o sea la cee está por
encima de la fotografía aquí lo vemos y
en el hashtag que tenemos ahí vemos cómo
son las letras rusas digamos pero
empieza con una zeta no del alfabeto del
alfabeto latino y está esta traducción
sería pues por la victoria raúl esta es
un poco pues la razón detrás de esta
insignia que estamos viendo tanto la
zeta del ejército ruso rosa el diario
punto es de españa explica quiénes son
los amigos íntimos de putin que pilotan
esta guerra así es hace un pequeño
repaso de lo que llama los asilo vi que
serían los hombres fuertes que coinciden
en haber entrado en contacto con el
poder a través de haber entrado durante
la época de la unión soviética pues en
los distintos servicios secretos se
trata de altos funcionarios políticos y
empresarios públicos que tienen mucho un
alto nivel de lealtad hacia putin y que
pues junto a él dirigen estrechamente
esta guerra en ucrania y entre ellos
encontramos serguéi lávrov quizás es de
los más conocidos en occidente el
ministro de exteriores pero también por
ejemplo el ministro de defensa sergei
shoigú que pues es uno de los
principales artífices del apoyo
al assad en síria y uno de los que se
perfila como el sucesor de putin rosa
gracias entonces por esta revista de
prensa mañana tenemos una sección muy
interesante y bastante especial de esta
revista de prensa una sorpresa que
mañana pues se lo vamos a revelar a
nuestros televidentes gracias rosa
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día